foreign
[Music]
my name is Colin Glasper and I'm going
to be talking about comparing package
versions I work for jumping Rivers
essentially can be summarized as we do
everything with r and pythons you need
help with that if you've been around the
exhibit stands we also do a smashing a
side project on coasters
and do you know how hard it is to get
500 courses through U.S customs
it's surprisingly difficult even when
you say you're going to an R Studio
conference you just think that should
explain it all so if you want to hear
that story come and have a chat as well
so
we all love our you know you start your
project you pull out wonderful packages
you do some amazing code and then you're
about to present your results you think
I could just update my packages what's
the worst that could happen
surely well not a lot could have changed
where we've all been there and you've
gone from praising the our Gods to
swearing at them and cursing them and
hating everything about it and it says
what the question is when are packages
updated
how do you find out what's changed all
right so is
it's been an easy question how do you
find out if what's changed
well
if the gods are smiling in your favor
and the package author has been
wonderful so here's Liberty you can see
you've got a nice news file my news
files are not like this
but he's obviously it's you know nice
links to issues
new features bug fixes it's all very
nice you know it's great you know your
clickable links it tells you exactly
what's going on
there may even be a little blog post by
the authors you know detailing exactly
what's changed and you had a good
workout and that's good you know so
that's if you're lucky you know the buds
buds are singing the Sun's shining if
you're unlucky well you might have to go
to the get repo this is liberal dates
get repo they're just trying to keep the
consistence though
and that's not bad right you know in the
grand scheme of things going through
someone's get reports definitely better
than nothing and it is it's okay
you might just be relying on something
like our weekly for example to sort of
help you figure out what's going on and
that that could be another way of
figuring it out
and if you've done something to upset
essentially uh everyone then essentially
download the target Zed fell from cran
and you're trying to unzip that and you
try and work your way through
and these people here are essentially
showing fake consultant happiness so
fake consultant happiness in my mind is
when your your client asks you to do
something you really don't want to and
so you just go yes that's fine of course
I'll do that so have you ever gone
through the source code it's not a fun
process because you're trying to figure
it out
and this is with different fight came in
so this is defined.com and he says it's
trying to make that that package
difference easier so you go to
differenti.com you click on R and then
you you put in your package of of that
you want and this is a team effort so
it's around about 10 contributors and
all of them done an amazing job at
coding with the exception of me who's
standing here presenting who's done no
coding quartzsoever uh so I'm living the
dream of not doing any of the real work
but standing presenting it so thank you
to all the other nine people who've done
the work so as an example I thought well
we'll go for Liberty type in Liberty and
that's a package
and then you get to choose which version
you want to compare so you've got one
you're going from too we've gone back to
round about I think it's 2017. we're
probably going to go you know we'll keep
knocking off a year until things start
breaking in the passing and then we'll
think yeah probably not go back any
further we reckon roundabout 2014 but
just now 2017 is fine
so here we're going to compare version
1.8 with 1.79
the news is next split up so we can see
that it's been a few releases
1.792 wasn't actually on Crown but that
news fair was kicking about somewhere so
all the other news news part
highlights what's changed so just grab
the news
more useful
you can actually start exploring quartz
change programmatically so sometimes
there's not a news file sometimes the
news file is incomplete so here we can
see that rcpp has been removed as a an
import from Liberty over the last
version
we can look at the namespace file and
again we get the same idea here so we've
had four functions added to the
namespace file and that that version
change so we can have a little look
uh we can look at the functions and here
we can see where we've got four
functions added and one of them have the
the arguments have changed
and then we can click on that and we can
see exactly which arguments have changed
in this function so here we can see that
the second positional argument has
changed and that could cause something
seriously bad to go with your code right
so if you're relying on additional
arguments that could be a bit of a
problem
so the roadmap is the next step is we're
going to have CI CD for package divs so
essentially you're working on GitHub and
you can automatically put up your
version you know 0.9 000 and so you can
sort of see what's happening in the day
version python should have been released
last week it's now going to be released
next month that's life isn't it and
essentially we've got a whole bunch of
other things but if you've got ideas
please come up and see or tweet or email
or anything like that and really happy
for suggestions happy for questions and
feel free to go to devified.com and get
a feel for what's going on thanks
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]